Transcriber: Sara Desouky
Gözden geçirme: Emel Çırakoğlu
Merhabalar.
Ben Defne Pelet’in kurucusu
olarak tanıtıldım.
Ancak ben bir hayal kurucusuyum.
Şimdi size hayal kurmanın ne kadar değerli
ve önemli bir şey olduğunu
anlatan küçük bir hikaye anlatacağım.
Benim anlatacağım bu şey okula giderken
okuduğum kitaplarda yazmıyordu.
Yıllar öncesinde Suriye sınırında yaşarken
ailemin fazlalık odası olarak
ayırdığı bir yer vardı.
Bu alan birçok kişi için, ailemdeki birçok
kişi için fazlalık odası idi.
Benim içinse hayallerime açılan bir dünya.
Kendimi bulduğum yer.
Fil dişinden kulemdi.
Yıllar öncesinde çocuk kalbimle bazı
hayaller kurmuştum ve bu hayallerime
sadece üniversite sınavında alacağım
diplomayla ulaşabileceğimi
inandırmıştım kendimi.
O benim tek hayalimdi.
Yüksek bir puan alacaktım ve hayallerimi
gerçekleştirecektim.
Sınava heyecanla hazırlandım
ve sınava girdim.
Ancak sınavıma 10 kala bazı ailevi
problemlerle karşılaştım.
Sınav sonuçlarım açıklanmıştı.
Beklediğim sonuçlar istediğim
gibi değildi.
Bu sonuçlar beni hayallerime götürecek
kapıyı aralamayacaktı bana.
Sonra o an hayallerimin yıkıldığını
düşündüm ama hayallerime yeniden tutundum.
Şöyle demiştim: “Ben iki yıllık bir
okula gideceğim ancak burayı
...bir araç olarak kullanacağım...”
...DGS sınavıyla istediğim
yeri kazanacağım.”
Çünkü bu benim hayalimdi.
2 yıllık bir serüvene başladım.
2 yılın sonunda yine heyecanla sınava
yine hazırlanırken, yine bazı
olumsuzluklarla karşılaştım ve ben
okulumu bırakmak zorundayım.
Zorunda kaldım.
Tekrar döndüm; Suriye sınırı dediğim yere.
Ne olacaktı şimdi?
Benim hayallerim vardı.
Yıllar öncesinde
hayaller kuruyordum ben.
Bir gün bir sahneye çıkacaktım.
Bir gün insanlara bazı şeyler anlatacaktım
ve anlattığım şeyler sonrasında
insanlar umutlu olacaktı.
Ben hayallerimde hep en yukarıda
hayal ettim kendimi.
Kendime ait bir yerim olacaktı.
Duvarlarımı da istediğim
renge boyayacaktım.
Peki ne olacaktı?
Benim hayallerim vardı.
Ben tam da o anda o Suriye’nin ışıklarına
bir gün bakarken,
kendi kendime şu cümleyi kullandım:
“Ben Rağmenci olmak istiyorum.“
İşte benim kalbimde inanılmaz bir
güç hissettiren bu cümleyle
elimdekilere odaklandım.
Elimdekiler neydi ve ben ne yapabilirdim?
Tesadüfen karşılaştığım bazı
olaylar sonucunda,
o Suriye sınırında küçük
bir yer kurdum kendime.
Benimdi ve üstelik istediğim renge,
boyayabilecektim orayı.
Büyük bir heyecanla, büyük umutlarla
işletmemi büyütmek istedim.
Tam da o anda oğlum dünyaya geldi.
İkisi de benim çocuğum da artık,
iki tane çocuğum vardı.
ve ikisini de büyütecektim.
İkisinin de bana ihtiyacı vardı.
ve ikisini de aynı
özveriyle büyütmeliydim.
Oğlum şimdi 5 yaşında.
Kurduğum, kurduğum işletmem de büyüdü.
Türkiye’de o Suriye sınırında üretmiş
olduğumuz ürünler
Türkiye’deki birçok ile gönderildi.
Bununla da kalmayıp sınırları aştı.
İtalya’dan Almanya’ya, Finlandiya’dan
Lübnan’a kadar o alın teri dediğim
ürünlerim gönderildi.
Evet, tutkum olmuştu,
benim tutkum olmuştu.
Kilometrelerce uzaklara alın terimi
gönderebilmek. Tutkum olmuştu,
çocuğumla birlikte çalışabilmek,
tutkum olmuştu, o şehirde,
her şeye rağmen bir şeyleri
başardım diyebilmek.
Bir gün herkes çabamı görecekti.
Ben inanmıştım.
Nerede olduğum önemli değildi.
Kendime kattığım değer ve güzel
duygularla çalışmak
aslında her şeyi çözerdi.
Ben inanmıştım.
Çünkü eğer gerçekten inanırsan, kağıttan
kuşlar bile uçabilirdi.
Bu mümkündü.
Bir gün kitapçıda dolaşırken
kendime bir dergi aldım.
Almış olduğum dergide yılın kadın
girişimcileri tanıtılıyordu.
Ve o dergide okuduğum tek sayfa orasıydı.
O an bir hayal kurdum.
Dedim ki bir gün ben de bu
dergide olmak istiyorum.
Bir gün ben de yılın kadın
girişimcisi olmak istiyorum.
Herkes göstermeli.
Bakın işte Ayşegül Yılın Kadın
Girişimcisi seçilmiş.
Bu şekilde hayallerle tabii
ki daha çok çalışarak...
2021 yılında Türkiye'nin Kadın
Girişimcisi seçildim.
Bu çok çok mutlu, çok mutluluk verici
bir şeydi, inanılmazdı.
O Suriye sınırı
dediğim yere film setleri kurulmuştu.
Çünkü herkes beni tanıtmaya çalışıyordu.
Hani yıllardır hayal kurmuştum.
Çaba göstermek için bazı şeylerin
mümkün olduğunu göstermek için.
Şu an her şey sanki bir çorap söküğü
gibi kendiliğinden ilerliyordu.
Tarifsiz bir mutluluk.
Her ilden insanlar yanıma geliyordu
beni tanımak için.
Sonra zaman bu mutlulukla, bu güzel
duygularla ilerledikçe çevremdeki çoğu
kişinin yıllardır kurmuş olduğum hayalleri
sahiplendiğini gördüm.
O en çok sevdiklerimin o en
çok güvendiklerimin
“Ben olmasaydım hiçbir şey yapamazdın”
deyişlerini, beni inandırdıklarını
görmeye başlamıştım.
Bu benim reddettiğim bir şeydi.
Tabii ki de bana destekler olmuştu.
Çünkü onlar benim en güvendiklerimdi; ama
bu benim başarımı sahiplenebilecek
bir şey değildi.
Çünkü ben tüm bu yaşadıklarımı
birilerin desteğinden çok
o çocuk kalbimde kurduğum hayallerin
evreni harekete geçirmesiyle
elde edildiğine
inananlardandım.
Çünkü evren bana inanmıştı.
Evren benim kalbimin hangi ritimde
attığını duymuştu.
Hani bir şeye çok inanırsınız ya,
etrafınızdaki insanlar daha siz bir şey
yapmadan o hayalinizi gerçekleştirmek
için harekete geçerler.
Bunu yapan aslında sizin kalbiniz.
Bunu yapan aslında evren.
Benim yaşadığım şey de tam
olarak buydu aslında.
Yaklaşık bir yıldır da ben kalbimde
bazı şeylerin savaşını veriyorum.
Benim sayemdecilere hayır
diyebilmenin savaşını.
Değiştiremeyeceğim her şeye, her şeye
arkamda arkamı kalbimin
reddettiklerini, beynimin reddettiklerini,
hayır diyebilmeyi
bu geçtiğimiz 1 yıl içerisinde öğrendim.
Etrafımdaki insanların küçük hesapları ve
benim sayemdecilere ile kaybedecek
bir saniyemiz bile yok.
O yüzden her şeyi geride bırakmayı
istedim gönülden.
Yeni tutkularım olmuştu.
Yeni tutkularım da zaman ve mekan
kaygısı yaşamadan çalışacaktım.
Herhangi bir yerde olacaktım.
Doğuda, batıda, güneyde, kuzeyde,
herhangi bir yerde.
Ben orada da paramı kazanacaktım.
Orada da hayaller kuracaktım ve sadece
kalbime hesap verecektim.
Sonra bu düşüncelerle, sürekli her gün
günlüğüme yazdığım düşüncelerimi
günlüğüme yazdığım
defterime
bir şeyler karaladım.
orada şöyle bir cümle yazıyordu.
“Benim hayatımın ikinci bölümü
başlıyor ve öncesini anlattığın
güzel defter,
sana elveda demek istiyorum.”
Bu yazıyı 4 Şubat'ta yazdım.
Sonra 4 Şubat'ta yeni defterime bu
defa sadece hayallerimi yazdım.
Hayallerimde bu evi değiştirecektim,
farklı bir yere gidecektim.
Sadece ve sadece kalbime hesap verecektim.
Mekan kaygısı yaşamadan
yaşayabilmeyi öğrenecektim.
Tam da 6 Şubat'ta üstünden iki gün
geçtikten sonra inanılmaz bir şey oldu.
Ben Hatay depremini yaşadım.
Hatay’daydım.
Yalnızdım ve çok mucizevi
bir şekilde kurtuldum.
Tesadüfen bulmuş
olduğum aracımın
anahtarıyla o kapıdan nasıl
çıktığımı bile bilmiyorum.
Bu halen benim hazedebildiğim
bir şey değil.
Sadece bir buçuk dakika, bir buçuk
dakikada her şeyinizi kaybettiğinizi,
hayatınızın altüst olduğunu düşünün.
Üstünden yaklaşık elli gün geçti.
Ben şimdi İzmir’deyim.
Dönüp ardıma bakıyorum geçtiğimiz 50 güne,
ve o yeni defterime yazdığım şeylere...
Evet, evimi değiştirdim.
Sanırım şu an mekan kaygımı
da gidermeye başladım.
Bir şekilde hayata tutunmaya
başladım tekrardan.
Ve sadece kalbime hesap veriyorum.
Son olarak da bir gün sosyal medyada
dolaşırken kendimi bulduğum...
bir anlatıyla bitirmek
istiyorum söyleyeceklerimi.
Işığınızı söndürmelerine izin vermeyin.
“Bu sadece bir mum” diyecekler.
“Ne var ki bunun ışığında,
bir üflesen söner”
Gaz lambası olacaksınız belki sonra,
“Gaz bitince sönecek” diyecekler.
Abajur olacaksınız,
“Bunun da bir ömrü var, elbet
tükenecek.” diyecekler.
Siz güneş olun.
Neden biliyor musunuz?
Mum olursanız kibrite,
gaz lambası olursanız benzine, abajur
olursanız elektriğe ihtiyacınız olacak.
Birileri size
“hep benim sayemde” diyecek
“Ben olmasam bir hiçsin, ben olmasam
başaramazsınız” diyecekler.
Siz güneş olun, ışığınızı söndürmelerine,
ışığınızdan hak iddia etmelerine
asla izin vermeyin.